Has standing to submit to it the dispute with Israel
concerning alleged violations
of obligations under the Genocide Convention.
The court then turns to the question of the rights
whose Protection is sought
and the link between such
rights and the measures requested.
It recalls that it's power to indicate
provisional measures under Article 41 of the statute
has as its object
the preservation of the respective rights
claimed by the party's inner case
pending its decision on the merits thereof.
It follows that the court must be concerned to preserve
by such measures
the rights which may subsequently
be adjudged by it to belong to either party.
Therefore, the court may exercise
this power only if it is satisfied
that the rights asserted by the party
requesting such measures
are at least plausible.
At this stage of the proceedings, however,
the court is not called upon to determine
definitively whether the rights
which South Africa wishes to seek protected exist.
It need only
decide whether the rights claim by South Africa
and for which it seeks Protection
are plausible.
Moreover, a link
must exist between the rights whose
Protection is sought
and the provisional measures being requested.
The court recalls that
in accordance with Article 1 of the convention,
all States parties there too
have undertaken to prevent and to punish
the crime of genocide.
Article 2 provides that, I quote,
genocide means any of the following acts
committed with an intent to destroy,
inhaler in part
a national ethnical,
racial Or religious group as such, a,
killing members of the group. B,
causing serious
bodily or mental harm to members of the group. C,
deliberately inflicting on the group conditions of life
calculated to bring about its physical destruction
in hollering part d,
imposing measures
intended to prevent births within the group.
E, forcing, forcibly
transferring children of the group to another group,
end of quote.
Pursuant to article 3 of the Genocide Convention,
the following
acts are also prohibited by the convention,
conspiracy to commit genocide,
direct and public incitement to commit then genocide,
attempt to commit genocide,
and complicity in genocide.
The provisions of the convention
are intended to protect the members of a national,
ethnical, racial
or religious group from acts of genocide
or any other punishable acts enumerated in article 3.
The court considers that there is a correlation between
the rights of members of groups
protected under the Genocide Convention,
the obligations incumbent on state parties there too,
and the right of any state party
to seek compliance there with
by another state party.
As the court has stated in other cases,
in order for acts to fall within the scope of
Article 2 of the convention,
the intent must be to destroy at least a substantial
part of a particular group.
This is demanded
by the very nature of the crime of genocide,
since the object and purpose of the convention
as a whole is to prevent the intentional
destruction of groups.
The part Part targeted must be significant enough
to have an impact on the group as a whole.
The Palestinians appear to constitute a distinct
national, ethnical,
racial or religious group
and hence a protected group within the meaning of
Article 2 of the Genocide Convention.
The court observes that
according to United Nations sources,
the Palestinian population in the Gaza Strip
comprises over 2 million people.
Palestinians in the Gaza Strip
form a substantial part of the protected group.
The court notes that the military
operation being conducted by Israel
following the attack of 7 October twenty twenty three
has resulted in a large number of deaths and injuries,
as well as massive destruction of homes,
the forcible displacement of the vast
majority of the population
and extensive damage to civilian infrastructure.
While figures relating to the Gaza
Strip cannot be independently verified,
recent information indicates
that 25,700 Palestinians have been killed,
over 63,000 injuries have been reported,
over 360 housing units have been destroyed
or partially damaged
and approximately 1.7 million persons
have been internally displaced.
The court takes note in this regard
of the statement by the United Nations
Under Secretary General for Humanitarian Affairs
and Emergency Relief Coordinator,
Mr Martin Griffiths
on 5 January 2024.
I quote, Gaza has become a place of death and despair.
Families are sleeping in the open
as temperatures plummet.
Areas where civilians were told to relocate
for their safety have come under bombardment.
Medical facilities are under relentless attack.
A public health disaster is unfolding.
Gaza has simply become uninhabitable.
Its people are witnessing
daily threats to their very existence
while the world watches on.